in the first of the year how you
feel being here was very happy and
returning to this world that is
wonderful perhaps i wrote javid as
unbeaten 5 world
in the form of a book
alfonso
de mother's day the world of the amazing
people
field at the heritage of the country  about the film
that you feel about what has happened with the
film and if you knew that something like this was going to happen
then I feel very happy because it is
a way of paying homage to all
these women from the homes and our
others I say it personally
and well I am  very happy with how
the film
automatic works and it's all around
modern has been received
[Music]
[Applause]